auch ihr Leben das Leben der
Präsidentenfamilie wie hat sich das
unter dem Eindruck dieses Krieges
verändert wie oft sehen sie ihren Mann
unter diesen
Umständen dieser Krieg verändert alles
verändert
Familien teilt sie
auf wir können nicht zusammen leben
können nicht als Familie zusammen sein
wir leben mit den Kindern mein Mann ist
die ganze Zeit bei der Arbeit wir sehen
uns
[Musik]
sporadisch jedoch nicht regelmäßig er
fehl den
Kindern zum Glück wissen wir wofür wir
alle kämpfen wofür er
kämpft warum wir nicht zusammen sein
können er hat keine Schuld daran Kinder
verstehen das wunderbar wir möchten
einfach mehr Zeit mehr Zeit zusammen
verbringen